[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'enfer du décor ou comment résumer en 5
mots le rapport choc que notre
délégation au droit des femmes a publié
en septembre dernier
mots d'une industrie licencieuse qui
prospère en irriguant la toile de
contenu illicite avec mes trois
collègues co-rapporteurs Alexandra
borque Fontain Laurence Cohen Laurence
Rossignol nous avons pour la première
fois dans l'histoire parlementaire
enquêté pendant 6 mois sur la réalité
des pratiques de l'industrie
pornographique nous avons entendu toutes
les parties prenantes dont à huis clos
des victimes de l'affaire French boukake
cette affaire a permis de mettre au
grand jour les pratiques de producteurs
de barbares qui ont détruit la vie de
dizaines de femmes nous avons analysé
les principaux contenus disponibles sur
les sites pornographiques ces
plateformes en ligne les tubes qui
proposent gratuitement et sans aucun
contrôle des millions de vidéos il faut
sortir de toute vision datée faussée et
du Corée du porno le porno aujourd'hui
ce sont des contenus violents dégradants
humiliant les scènes dans lesquelles un
homme ou plus souvent des hommes
infligent des violences physiques et
sexuelles à des femmes sont devenus la
norme la pornographie n'est pas du
cinéma les pleurs les cris les viols le
sang il n'y a pas d'effets spéciaux tout
est vrai ce sont ces violences et leur
banalisation qui nous ont amenés à
prendre des positions fortes notre
rapport a eu un écho médiatique
considérable en France et à
l'international suscitant une onde de
choc dans l'opinion le nombre de
cosignataires de cette proposition de
résolution
255 exactement
constituent un record jamais atteint
pour un sexe pardon pour un texte
sénatorial sous la Cinquième République
excusez-moi cela
ce chiffre témoigne d'une prise de
conscience collective plus que d'inviter
il engage le gouvernement à mettre en
oeuvre les recommandations que nous
avons formulées les ministres à qui nous
avons présenté le rapport nous ont
assuré vouloir avancer sur ce sujet je
pense bien sûr à la sulution de contrôle
d'âge annoncé récemment par Jean-Noël
Barrault et Charlotte cobel ainsi qu'à
toutes les mesures de politiques pénale
qui permettront de poursuivre les
auteurs et diffuseurs la massification
de la production et de la consommation
nous oblige je sais pouvoir compter sur
vous madame la ministre vous partagez
notre détermination nos propositions
sont sur la table le gouvernement doit
s'en saisir je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
maintenant madame la Présidente Laurence
Rossignol l'auteur de la proposition de
résolution pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
présidente de la délégation droit des
femmes chers collègues je vais pour ma
part évoquer
la dimension industrielle du porno nous
avons effectivement voulu que notre
rapport s'intéresse à l'industrie
pornographique pas simplement à l'effet
du porno à qui en consomme toute la
chaîne qui part du recrutement des
méthodes de tournage des méthodes de
diffusion puis de l'influence sur les
cerveaux et la société sur les jeunes
comme sur les adultes car le porno c'est
d'abord une industrie mondialisée qui
génère plusieurs milliards d'euros de
profits chaque année concentrés dans les
mains de quelques grandes
multinationales souvent basées dans des
paradis fiscaux la production massive de
contenus pornographiques et de plus en
plus violente ces contenus sont violents
sont extrêmes et la production est de
plus en plus volumineuse elle alimente
ce business mondial et génère un trafic
vidéo prépondérant sur Internet
les vidéos pornographiques hébergées sur
des plateformes de streaming constituent
ainsi plus d'un quart de tout le trafic
vidéo en ligne du monde la demande de
contenu porno sur internet correspond
quant à elle à une à une recherche sur 8
quand il s'agit d'un ordinateur et une
recherche sur 5 quand il s'agit d'un
mobile et ne nous voyons pas la face mes
chers collègues nous recherchent
statistiques ont montré que la France
est un des pays les plus consommateurs
de pornographie au monde le porno c'est
aussi une industrie qui par sa nature
même est génératrice de violence
systémiques envers les femmes n'oublions
pas la définition de la pornographie il
s'agit de l'exploitation commerciale de
la représentation explicite d'actes
sexuels non simulés or d'après les
chiffres publiés notre rapport 90% des
scènes pornographiques comportent des
violences sexuelles physiques ou
verbales ces violences ne sont pas
simulées mais sont bien réelles pour les
femmes filmées
nous avons également constaté au cours
de nos travaux une grande porosité entre
l'univers pornographique et l'univers de
la prostitution ce sont deux mondes
entre lesquels les passerelles sont
nombreuses et qui utilisent des méthodes
de recrutement similaires pour exploiter
sexuellement les mêmes femmes
vulnérables économiquement socialement
et souvent psychologiquement enfin le
porno est une industrie qui fait
maintenant l'objet de poursuite pénale
enfin il était temps pour la première
fois en France des violences commises
dans un contexte de pornographie sur des
femmes victimes de graves maltraitance
sexuelles physiques et psychologique
font l'objet d'un traitement pénal les
auteurs de ces violences sont
poursuivies pour viol viol aggravé
complicité de viol avec acte de torture
et de barbarie traitent des êtres
humains en fin de viol proxénétisme
voilà la réalité de cette industrie
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi nous appelons
à faire de la lutte contre les violences
pornographiques une priorité de
politique publique l'omerta qui pèse sur
ces violences à cesser il est temps de
mettre un terme au déni à la
complaisance dont bénéfice des industrie
depuis trop longtemps et pour cela nous
avons madame la ministre besoin de votre
engagement à nos côtés nous savons que
déjà ce sujet vous mobilise et nous
espérons beaucoup de l'ensemble du
gouvernement enfin ma collègue par Laura
dans quelques instants de l'influence du
porno sur les jeunes cerveaux mais je
vous dis dire que le porno n'est pas
toxique que pour les adolescents le
porno est toxique pour l'ensemble des
consommateurs de porno y compris pour
les adultes pour ces hommes qui sont
devenus addict au porno et ne sont plus
capables d'avoir une sexualité réelle
tant ils sont motivés et excités
exclusivement par les scènes violentes
qu'il voit sur Internet merci merci
madame la Présidente la parole est
maintenant à Madame Alexandra borchio
fond de teint auteur de la proposition
de résolution pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues co-rapporteurs chers
collègues porno l'enfer du décor un jeu
de mot pour arrêter de jouer avec les
plus fragiles et pour dénoncer les
conséquences de la massification des
contenus pornographiques des
consommateurs toujours plus nombreux de
plus en plus jeunes en demande de
contenu de plus en plus violent extrême
et dégradant ce sont aussi les
conséquences de l'accoutumance mais
jusqu'où ira cette surenchère malsaine
une escalade infernale pour tenter
d'assouvir une curiosité qui finalement
n'est jamais comblée et ce sont
considérations pour les conditions dans
lesquelles ces contenus sont produits
deux tiers des moins de 15 ans et 1/3
des enfants de moins de 12 ans ont déjà
eu accès à des images pornographiques
triste réalité lorsqu'on sait que
l'exposition des mineurs à ce type de
contenu s'inscrit en parfaite violation
du code pénal car comme vous le savez
depuis la loi du 30 juillet 2020 à
initiative de notre collègue Marie
Mercier que je veux saluer pour ces
travaux sur ce sujet précis les sites
pornographiques ont l'obligation de
s'assurer de la majorité de l'internaute
qui les consulte et pourtant tous les
sites pornos demeurent accessibles en un
clic sans aucune vérification d'âge tout
comme les réseaux sociaux devenus
aujourd'hui le support social de
référence des nouvelles générations sur
lesquelles de nombreux comptes affichent
des contenus pornographiques violents
bien loin de la réalité et qui ont pour
conséquence de banaliser ces pratiques
sexuelles comme si elles étaient la
norme se poser des questions sur la
sexualité quand on est à l'école
primaire est une curiosité finalement
naturelle qui fait partie de son
développement en revanche aller chercher
des réponses sur les plateformes
numériques qui proposent des contenus
adaptatif inadaptés avec leur maturité
et absolument par représentative de la
réalité pose un sérieux problème là
aussi il y a un effort à fournir en
matière de prévention afin de
sensibiliser les enfants et les parents
aux dangers de la photographie et de la
marchandisation du corps les
conséquences sur la genèse de cette
exposition massive au porno sont plus
que préoccupantes et elles ne
s'élimitent pas qu'aux mineurs bien sûr
le porno peut également avoir un impact
dangereux sur les adultes sur leur
représentation de même des femmes et de
la sexualité face à ce constat alarmant
il est donc urgent d'agir dans notre
rapport nous avons proposé notamment la
mise en place d'un dispositif
d'attestation de majorité reposant sur
un principe de double anonymat plus que
des annonces nous attendons maintenant
des actes forts madame la ministre mes
chers collègues avec Annick billon
Laurence Cohen et Laurence Rossignol
nous avons abordé ce sujet tabou parce
qu'il nous a semblé majeurs nous avons
entendu à huis clos des témoignages
glaçants surréalistes de victimes de
violence mais aussi d'adolescents dans
un collège à quelques encablures d'ici
qui considèrent que le corps peut être
une monnaie d'échange il est temps
d'ouvrir les yeux et d'agir pour que
notre pays ne soit plus complice de
cette triste réalité avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard pour rectifier je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Laurence Cohen auteur
de la proposition de résolution pour 3
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues porno l'enfer du
décor la délégation au droit des femmes
du Sénat et aujourd'hui le Sénat tout
entier peuvent être fiers de ce rapport
un véritable pavé dans la mare lancé il
y a quelques mois il y aura notamment
permis de mettre à l'agenda du
gouvernement le sujet des pratiques de
l'industrie pornographique et de ses
violences il aura aussi contribué à
sensibiliser l'opinion publique à ces
violences et à les mettre au coeur du
débat public de ce point de vue nous
pouvons considérer que notre rapport
pionnier a beaucoup d'égards est une
réussite en soi au-delà de cette école
médiatique et populaire nous attendons
aujourd'hui des avancées concrètes suite
au 23 recommandations formulées dans
notre rapport je rappelle rapidement les
quatre grands axes de ces
recommandations premièrement faire de la
lutte contre les violences
pornographiques une priorité de
politique publique et pénale
deuxièmement faciliter la suppression de
contenus pornographiques illicite et
exercice du droit à l'oubli
troisièmement bloquer l'accès des
mineurs au contenu pornographique à cet
égard nous nous félicitons des récentes
annonces du gouvernement concernant la
mise en place dès le mois de mars d'un
dispositif technique opérationnel de
vérification d'âge reposant sur le
principe du double anonymat tel que
celui que nous avions proposé dans notre
rapport et que viendraper notre collègue
Alexandra borchio Fontain enfin
quatrième et dernier axe de nos
recommandations l'éducation des jeunes à
la sexualité et la sensibilisation des
parents des équipes pédagogiques et des
professionnels de santé aux dangers de
l'exposition à la pornographie des
enfants et adolescents globalement nous
pensons qu'il est nécessaire de mettre
en oeuvre un plan interministériel de
lutte contre les violences
pornographiques avec des mesures fortes
dans les quatre domaines que je viens de
citer pour mettre en oeuvre un tel plan
il faudra bien sûr des moyens importants
adaptés et nouveau notamment un
renforcement de l'arsenal pénal des
effectifs et des moyens matériels mais à
disposition des services enquêteurs et
des magistrats à mener à traiter des
violences commises dans un contexte de
pornographie nous sommes également
favorables à l'exploration de toutes les
mesures fiscales permettant de taxer
l'activité de l'industrie pornographique
marcher extrêmement rentable qui génère
des milliards d'euros de profits chaque
année bref nous revendiquons sans des
tours un pouvoir de nuisances à
l'encontre de cette industrie aussi
puissante que néfastes unissons nos
forces dans ce combat pour que 505 les
violences systémiques induites par les
pratiques de cette industrie c'est l'une
des conditions pour bâtir une société
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
nous sommes toutes et tous concernés et
nous pouvons être fiers d'examiner
aujourd'hui cette proposition au Sénat
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est
maintenant Madame Véronique Guillotin
pour le groupe RDSE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la délégation au
droit des femmes cher Annick mesdames
les auteurs de la proposition de
résolution mes chers collègues pour
reprendre un constat évident du rapport
d'information de mes collègues Annick
Bilon Alexandra borschoffontin Laurence
Cohen et Laurence Rossignol le milieu de
la pornographie est aujourd'hui et avant
tout un business et un business qui peut
rapporter gros à l'instar de secteur qui
situe souvent au-delà de la légalité
qu'on pense à la prostitution au trafic
en tout genre il est difficile d'obtenir
des statistiques précises sur l'ampleur
et les caractéristiques du phénomène on
sait toutefois que les volumes
d'affaires ce chiffre en milliard
d'euros il s'agit aujourd'hui d'un
secteur concentré dans les mains de
quelques plateformes de diffusion à
l'échelle mondiale ça a été dit souvent
d'origine nord-américaine mais dont les
sièges sociaux peuvent être établis dans
des paradis fiscaux et qui se
caractérise souvent par une certaine
opacité financière la diffusion et la
consommation de contenu pornographiques
et massive représentant le quart de la
bande passante d'Internet les
plateformes dites pour adulte font
partie des sites les plus consultés
comparables au grand moteur de recherche
aux réseaux sociaux au grand média etc
la France occupe je dirais hélas la
quatrième place mondiale dans la
consommation de contenu pour adultes
les critiques sur l'évolution de
l'industrie pornographique ne sont pas
nouvelles en ce qui concerne ses effets
sur le consommateur notamment les plus
jeunes mais pas que qu'ils soient
volontaires ou accidentel mais ces
critiques ont pris plus récemment un
tour dramatique avec la révélation
d'abus particulièrement graves en France
même sur des jeunes femmes lors de
réalisation de tournage dit des
tournages amateurs la massification et
la banalisation de la pornographie
peuvent entraîner la recherche de
contenu toujours plus inventifs et par
conséquent des pratiques de plus en plus
extrêmes voire violente sans le
consentement réel des personnes nous
devons donc nous interroger davantage
sur les conditions de production des
contenus pour adultes et sur les règles
qui devraient encadrer ces productions
par exemple en imposant des médiateurs
du consentement ou des dispositifs
comparables
il ressort des travaux de la délégation
au droit des femmes que ces abusent
particulièrement l'industrie dite
amateur réalité qui cache en fait
l'absence totale de garantie pour les
jeunes femmes car ce sont elles le plus
souvent les victimes et une organisation
digne des labels les plus établies la
pornographie dite professionnelle n'est
pas pour autant exempt de critiques on
sait de longues dates que les conditions
de travail lors des tournages et les
conditions sanitaires les plus
élémentaires ne sont pas respectés c'est
un point important qui ressort des
auditions menées l'année dernière les
actrices qui refusent d'être assimilées
à des prostituées demande à être
reconnus en tant qu'actrice et à ce que
leur profession puisse s'organiser de
façon à mieux défendre leurs droits aux
moyens par exemple de syndicat
interprofessionnels d'agence au même
titre que pour les acteurs classiques en
tant que cossignataire de la proposition
de résolution qui fait l'objet d'un
consensus transpartisan je me permets
d'attirer l'attention sur ce point
j'en viens maintenant au deuxième axe de
la problématique l'effet de la
pornographie sur le public qu'on le
veuille ou non la portographie la
pornographie occupe aujourd'hui une
place importante sans pour autant qu'il
faille la considérer comme un produit de
consommation classique en ce qui
concerne les mineurs l'accès à la
pornographie et problématique dans la
mesure où ces contenus leur sont
interdits par la loi le contrôle de
l'âge est une difficulté réelle un
dispositif de certification de l'âge est
en cours d'élaboration pour une mise en
oeuvre cette année je rappellerai pour
ma part la loi du 2 mars 2022 visant à
renforcer le contrôle parental sur les
moyens d'accès à Internet adopter
adopter avec succès il y a un an est-ce
que l'on sait si d'ores et déjà cette
loi a produit ses effets
l'accès des adultes à la pornographie
quant à lui autorisé en France et plus
largement dans les pays occidentaux mais
souvent interdit ou limité dans le reste
du monde toutefois les effets de la
pornographie sur les adultes ne
devraient pas être négligées pour autant
soit parce qu'ils y sont confrontés
pendant l'adolescence soit parce qu'elle
contribue encore à donner une vision
déformée la sexualité enfin les adultes
ont naturellement une responsabilité
dans leur propre usage de la
pornographie et dans les conseils qu'ils
doivent apporter aux mineurs on évoque
là le sujet de l'éducation en conclusion
convaincue de la nécessité d'ajur plus
efficacement pour lutter contre les
dérives de cette industrie les membres
du RDS voteront pour l'adoption de cette
proposition de résolution
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Madame Laure
darkos pour le groupe les républicains
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui la
proposition de résolution de nos
collègues Annick billon que je salue
Alexandra borchio fontin Laurence Cohen
et Laurence
à faire de la lutte contre les violences
pornographiques une priorité de
politique publique que nous sommes
nombreux à avoir cosigné la pornographie
est partout et accessible d'un seul clic
tel un produit de consommation courante
le marché est si peu régulé qu'il suffit
de répondre à une question simplissime
avez-vous plus de 18 ans pour accéder à
des contenus sensibles que l'on soit
mineur ou majeur
une réponse positive permet d'entrer
dans l'univers sordide des vidéos porno
tournées avec des actrices parfois
vulnérables qui n'auraient jamais
consenti à l'acte sexuel si elles
avaient été informé des conditions de
tournage et des pratiques que ce milieu
ignorant de la dignité humaine leur
impose
le respect dû à la femme et à son
intégrité physique devenue de la chair à
canon pour des pornographes des
pornocrates sans scrupules elle doit
contribuer à leur fortune personnelle et
à leur gloire certains fatalistes
banaliseront la pornographie en
affirmant qu'elle n'est finalement
qu'une version modernisée de la
sexualité et c'est là que le bât blesse
car la pornographie aussi répandue
soit-elle ne peut être assimilée à la
sexualité qui est un découverte partagée
mettant en scène une intimité complice
plusieurs chercheurs auditionnés par
notre délégation nous ont confirmé que
ces vidéos ont une influence certaine
sur les pratiques des adolescents à
travers leur norme corporelle et les
dictats qu'elle impose pire elle
véhicule la culture du viol dans un
contexte où l'éducation à la sexualité
dans le cadre scolaire est quasi
inexistante
dans certains cas la consommation de
contenus pornographiques peut conduire à
des traumatismes psychologiques et
psychiques et physiques graves auquel
concours également les réseaux sociaux
numériques comme Instagram ou snapchat
snapchat je vais y arriver snapchat ou
l'image des corps dénudées et banalisée
et le Revenge porn une pratique courante
si les enjeux de prévention sont majeurs
ils ne sont cependant pas traités avec
suffisamment de détermination et de
moyens humains aujourd'hui dans notre
pays
la seconde réponse peut être apportée à
travers la mise en oeuvre d'une
politique coercitive beaucoup plus forte
à l'égard des éditeurs de contenu agir
sur le terrain juridique et renforcer
les outils techniques sont certainement
le meilleur moyen de réguler l'accès à
la pornographie la loi du 30 juillet
2020 visant à protéger les victimes de
violence conjugales a constitué une
étape importante en matière de lutte
contre les contenus Porto
pornographiques je tiens ici à celui
l'engagement ferme et constante de notre
collègue Marie Mercier sur ce sujet
essentiel de la protection de l'enfance
c'est à l'arcom qu'un comble désormais
la responsabilité de faire respecter
l'interdiction de l'accès des mineurs
aussi de pornographique elle s'y
récemment employée en mettant en demeure
plusieurs plateformes de rendre leur
contenu inaccessible puis en saisissant
le président du tribunal judiciaire de
Paris pour obtenir le blocage de l'accès
au site et leur déférencement
les éditeurs concernés se sont lancés
depuis dans une bataille juridique
acharnée afin de protéger leur activité
et le revenu l'indécence n'a décidément
pas de limite il faudra sans aucun doute
comme le propose la délégation aux
droits des femmes renforcer les pouvoirs
de l'arcome par exemple en assermentant
ces agents afin de leur permettre de
constater eux-mêmes les infractions des
éditeurs de contenu sensible la
possibilité de prononcer à leur
rencontre des sanctions administratives
avec des montants dissuasifs est aussi
parfaitement envisageable dans ce
contexte je me réjouis de l'annonce
récent par le gouvernement du test
prochain d'un dispositif technique
reposant sur le principe du double
anonymat destiné à vérifier l'âge des
internautes une telle solution plus
performante que celle actuellement
proposée par les éditeurs de contenu
seraient de nature à répondre aux
recommandations de notre délégation
enfin nous devons avoir conscience du
rôle pivot de l'éducation nationale et
de la nécessité d'aborder dans le cadre
de séances d'éducation à la vie sexuelle
et affective des sujets relatifs à la
marchandisation des corps et à la
pornographie de même serait-il judicieux
de recruter plus de professionnels
formés en matière d'éducation à la santé
dans les établissements scolaires c'est
assez conditions que nous pourrons faire
échec aux violences pornographiques et
permettront à nos enfants et adolescents
de vivre sereinement le passage
progressif vers l'âge adulte Contenu de
l'importance des enjeux et de la
nécessité d'agir sans délai contre ces
violences je voterai en faveur de la
proposition de résolution qui nous est
soumise je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Pierre maître viel
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
quel parent ne sait jamais interrogé sur
le type de contenu auquel son enfant
avait accès sur Internet
parmi les contenus qui inquiète il y a
évidemment sur le caractère
pornographique ils inquiète car la
plupart des parents veulent protéger
leurs enfants de ce type de vidéo tout
en sachant que l'accès à ses contenus
volontaires ou non relève justement bien
trop souvent d'une simplicité enfantine
ce qui interroge en revanche beaucoup
moins ce sont les conditions de tournage
de ces vidéos pourtant parfois
excessivement violente notamment envers
les actrices
quiconque consultait le rapport
d'information du Sénat porno l'enfer du
décor n'a pu être que bouleversé va
perturber à la lecture de certaines
témoignages de victimes
certains font clairement état d'un
système organisé d'abus de faiblesse de
viol et d'actes de torture et de
barbarie
je souhaite ainsi saluer le travail des
rapporteurs qui a permis de mettre en
lumière les dessous très tabous de
milieu qu'il est tout autant
la pornographie constitue déjà en
elle-même un genre de cinéma très
particulier dans lequel les actes les
plus intimes sont dissimulés ni fin mais
reproduits et lorsque ces actes inclus
des pratiques très violentes voire des
humanisantes non consenties on ne peut
plus du tout parler de cinéma
le sujet que nous abordons aujourd'hui
n'est pas celui d'être pour ou contre la
pornographie mais celui de condamner
totalement et formellement toute forme
de violences commises à l'encontre des
acteurs et des actrices de cette
industrie
ces dernières années le secteur amateur
s'est considérablement développé
notamment en raison du développement des
réseaux sociaux des messageries privées
et des plateformes gratuites entièrement
dédiées à ce type de contenu
pratique sexuelle imposée rapport forcé
nombre de partenaires excessifs les
tournages se font parfois dans des
conditions inhumaines si certains
producteurs tentent de mettre en place
des pratiques différentes respectueuses
des actrices et des acteurs de leur
dignité de leur consentement et de leur
condition de travail c'est pratique
reste malheureusement encore très
minoritaire
nous souhaitons également affirmer notre
volonté de renforcer la protection des
mineurs face à ce type de contenu car si
le code pénal interdit leur accès aux
mineurs il serait illusoire de prétendre
que telle n'est pas le cas en pratique
une simple déclaration de majorité
suffit pour accéder au site pour adultes
62% des adolescents ont déjà vu des
images pornographiques avant 15 ans et
31% avant 12 ans
plus inquiétant encore un enfant de
primaire sur deux il y a déjà été exposé
au-delà d'une simple déclaration un
véritable contrôle de l'âge devrait être
assuré avant l'accès à tout contenu
pornographique c'est là un point crucial
comment s'assurer de l'âge de
l'internaute tout en respectant la
confidence la confidentialité pardon des
données à caractère personnel
la piste principale proposée par le
pérenne et la CNIL pour les sites
pornographiques mais aussi plus
largement à tout site soumis à une
obligation vérification d'âge vise à ce
qui ne réalise pas eux-mêmes cette
vérification
elle devra s'appuyer sur des tiers de
confiance banque fournisseur d'énergie
dont la validité aura été vérifiée de
manière indépendante
aucun système cependant ne sera parfait
et aucun ne sera indétable il s'agira de
trouver la moins mauvaise des solutions
pour protéger les mineurs et cette
solution devra nécessairement s'inscrire
dans le cadre d'un débat démocratique
enfin et parce que l'actualité nous
irons voir il faut renforcer les moyens
permettant de lutter contre la
pédopornographie comment est-il possible
que de tel contenu soit encore
disponible aujourd'hui
en 2021 la plateforme Pharos a empêché
plus de 3 millions de consultations donc
90% concernés du contenu à caractère
pornographique mais combien de contenus
de ce type sont encore librement
accessibles
nous appelons un renforcement de
l'arsenal pénal des effectifs et des
moyens permettant de lutter contre toute
forme de violence pornographiques et de
diffusion de contenu illicites nous
espérons que cette proposition de
résolution donnera lieu à des mesures
concrètes et le groupe Les Indépendants
bien sûr en faveur de ses propositions
de résolution
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Monique de Marco pour
le groupe écologiste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues à quoi bon éduquer
les enfants à la notion de consentement
si des contenus pornographiques mettant
en scène des adultes qui en sont privés
leur serre de lieu d'apprentissage de la
sexualité par défaut selon les termes
cette résolution
contrairement au fantasme véhiculé par
ses contenus l'effet judiciaires à
l'origine cette initiative sont bien
réelles dès 2020 plusieurs teintes de
violent aggravés plainte d'être plainte
traite d'êtres humains et actes de
torture liés à des actes commisses des
plateaux et en des plateaux de tournage
ont été déposés
ces plaintes sont toujours en cours
d'instruction le Sénat s'est saisi de la
question donnant lieu à la publication
d'un rapport d'information en septembre
dernier et je tiens à saluer
l'initiative numéro 4
au moment de sa publication déjà
certains représentants du secteur et du
travailleur du sexe ont mis un avant la
possibilité d'une régulation alternative
et la nécessité de distinguer la
pornographie de la violence bien que de
jeunes productions offrent des contenus
destinés à un public plus large et
désormais féminins moins marqués par les
rapports du domination la margination du
secteur ne permet pas de garantir une
protection satisfaisante pour les
personnes engagées par ces productions
il est donc urgent de s'assurer que le
droit existant soit correctement
appliqué au regard surtout d'une
influence de ces contenus sur les
mineurs
il est vrai que les images véhiculant
les rapportent des domination ne relève
pas des seuls contenus pornographiques
mais ce secteur doit comme les autres
prendre sa part de responsabilité alors
que deux tiers des enfants de moins de
15 ans et un tiers des enfants de moins
de 12 ans ont déjà eu accès à de tels
contenus
on observe en outre un être retour des
perceptions sexistes chez les jeunes
générations selon le rapport du Haut
Conseil à l'égalité 23% des jeunes de 25
à 35 ans estiment qu'il faut parfois
être violent pour être respecté en tant
qu'homme et l'image des femmes véhicules
et pas la pornographie et jugé
problématique par seulement la moitié
d'entre eux
par ailleurs les travaux de la mission
d'information ont permis de mettre de
faire le constat des faibles moyens
d'action de l'arcome
lors d'une audition à la commission
culture en septembre dernier j'avais
interrogé le président de la recom sur
ses capacités de mettre en place un
écran noir en l'absence de vérification
de la majorité de l'utilisation du site
et de disposer d'agents assermentés pour
constater les infractions question
rester sans réponse le président de la
com a mis en avant des campagnes de
communication et signalétique celle-ci
me paraissent totalement insuffisante
c'est pourquoi avec d'autres de mes
collègues du groupe écologiste j'ai
signé cette proposition des résolutions
il s'agit également de poursuivre la
réflexion législative qui s'est ouverte
depuis plusieurs années sur l'existence
de violences sexuelle et sexistes
structuelles circulaires dans notre
société et les moyens de mettre en place
pour les empêcher une répétition
générationnelle
sans verser dans le prohibitisme trois
pistes devraient être examinées en
priorité
premièrement il importe de s’assurer que
les contenus soient produits dans des
conditions légales et respectueuses du
droit du travail et des personnes et de
la dignité humaine et que les
manquements donnent lieu à des sanctions
adaptées et un accompagnement des
victimes une réflexion pourrait s'ouvrir
également sur le soutien aux productions
plus respectueuse des droits des
personnes dans l'esprit des travaux
législatif conduits sur la prostitution
deuxièmement il importe de garantir que
les contenus pour adultes soient
réservés aux adultes autrefois le filtre
était assuré par un contrôle physique
des distributeurs de films à l'entrée
des salles de cinéma par exemple et dans
les vidéos club l'époque a changé la
digitalisation nécessite d'adapter les
outils de régulation dans le respect
bien sûr de la protection des données
personnelles
j'espère que le gouvernement parviendra
rapidement une dispositif efficace en
s'inspirant par exemple du modèle de la
Louisiane
troisièmement il faut impérativement
renforcer l'éducation à la sexualité qui
nécessite d'importants moyens humains et
matériels et ça c'est le rôle de
l'Éducation nationale
il me semble important de rappeler que
la consommation de pornographie n'est
qu'un aspect de la liberté sexuelle
quand des moyens de vivre ces fantasmes
et qu'il existe des sexualités heureuses
sans y avoir recours
donc totem est à bout Freud écrivez que
le besoin sexuel loin d'unir les hommes
les divise j'espère que nous pourrons
parvenir à dépasser ces divisions pour
parvenir à une régulation de toute la
pornographie respectueuse de toutes les
sexualité et de toutes les dignités je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame Samantha
casbone pour le groupe RDPI pour 6
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le rapport annuel
2023 sur l'état des lieux du sexisme en
France et marquant 48% des hommes entre
15 et 34 ans considèrent que l'image des
femmes véhiculées par les contenus
pornographiques et problématiques ce
chiffre monte à 79 % des hommes âgés de
65 ans et plus soit 30 points d'écart ce
constat est alarmant surtout quand on le
regarde alone d'un autre chiffre 90% des
scènes pornographiques comportent de la
violence comment se fait-il que des
images de violence choquent moins les
jeunes comment agir contre le sexisme en
France dans toutes les sphères où ce
dernier existe comment protéger mieux
les femmes aujourd'hui
dans ce contexte la délégation au droit
des femmes a réalisé un rapport
d'information sur les pratiques de
l'industrie pornographique c'est la
première fois qu'un tel travail est
réalisé et nous ne pouvons que nous en
féliciter car pour endiguer un phénomène
de violence pour protéger les femmes qui
en sont victimes pour encadrer une
industrie qui représente 25% du trafic
web de vidéos dans le monde il faut en
comprendre les acteurs les enjeux les
limites et les risques ce travail
parlementaire nous permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir une vision plus claire des
mesures à prendre pour avancer vers une
meilleure protection des femmes et des
mineurs face aux violences
pornographiques existantes c'est tout
l'objet de la proposition de résolution
qui nous est aujourd'hui soumis et que
j'ai souhaité qu'aux signer avec
plusieurs de mes collègues dans une ère
où les vidéos se diffusent en quelques
secondes aux quatre coins du monde où
les
régulations d'accès sont rendues
difficiles par les contenus disponibles
en quelques clics les mesures
protectrices sont recherchés par nombre
d'entre nous c'est ainsi que l'année
dernière la loi proposée par notre
collègue député Bruno struder visant à
renforcer le contrôle parental sur les
moyens d'accès Internet a été promulgué
elle rend obligatoire la
pré-installation d'un dispositif de
contrôle parental sur les appareils
connectés vendus en France l'activation
de ce dispositif devrait être proposé
gratuitement à l'utilisateur lors de la
première mise en service de l'équipement
le gouvernement s'est également engagé
sur le sujet avec notamment l'objectif
de mieux protéger les mineurs face à ses
contenus c'est ainsi qu'une campagne
gouvernementale sur le site je protège
mon enfant et les dispositifs de
contrôle parentaux a été lancé il y a
quelques semaines cette plateforme
d'information de prévention et de
protection des mineurs contre
l'exposition au contenu pornographique
en ligne propose des outils des conseils
et des ressources pratiques pour mieux
informer les parents afin qu'il protège
leurs enfants
de plus le rapport commandé par le
gouvernement concernant l'éducation à la
sexualité a été publiée en 2021 et
permet d'avoir un état des lieux dans la
mise en oeuvre de cette politique
publique il préconise notamment
d'inscrire des notions d'éducation à la
sexualité dans les programmes de
certaines disciplines appartenant au
domaine des sciences humaines
économiques et sociales est liées à
l'éducation de la sexualité enfin un
travail commun est actuellement mené par
Jean-Noël Barrault et Charlotte COBAL
pardon sur la vérification d'âge par le
biais de l'attestation numérique ainsi
il a été annoncé le lancement en mars
d'une expérimentation visant à trouver
une solution de vérification de l'âge
des internautes en double anonymat cette
annonce fait suite à un avis de la CNIL
sur ce sujet et il s'agira donc de
s'assurer de la mise en œuvre d'un outil
protecteur des mineurs mais également de
la vie privée et des données
personnelles de chacun
comme tout travail sur ces enjeux
centraux il faut donc parvenir à
l'équilibre il me semble que c'est
l'objet de la proposition de résolution
protégée avec justesse cette dernière
prévoit donc tout d'abord de demander
une prise de conscience collective de la
réalité des pratiques de l'industrie
pornographique et de leur conséquences
c'est un objectif essentiel le texte
vise également à faire de la lutte
contre les violences que cette industrie
génère est véhicule une priorité de
politique publique et pénale à mieux
informer accueillir et protéger les
victimes de violences commises dans un
contexte de pornographie en particulier
en formant les forces de l'ordre et les
intervenants du numéro national 39 19
à recommander la création d'une
catégorie violence sexuelle sur la
plateforme Pharos que vous connaissez
afin de faciliter et de mieux
comptabiliser les signalements
à protéger la jeunesse en bloquant tout
site ou réseau proposant des contenus
pornographiques sans exiger une preuve
de majorité des utilisateurs appelé des
pour une généralisation des dispositifs
de contrôle parental et de navigation
sécurisée qui pourrait être activée par
défaut dès lors qu'un abonnement
téléphonique est souscrit pour l'usage
d'un mineur et enfin à alerter sur la
nécessité d'appliquer les trois séances
annuelles d'éducation à la vie affective
et sexuelle et la nécessité d'aborder
lors de ses séances les sujets relatifs
à la marchandisation des corps et de la
pornographie cette proposition de
résolution vise ainsi à aller au-delà
d'un mot connu de tous la pornographie
ce dernier utilisait d'ailleurs trop
souvent par les mineurs qui ont parfois
accès à ces contenus avant même d'en
apprendre davantage sur les notions de
consentement de sexualité et les
problématiques liées à ces dernières le
texte en s'attachant à trouver une
réponse exhaustive tant sur
l'information le contrôle la formation
et la protection des plus fragiles nous
apparaît d'importance c'est pour ces
raisons que le groupe RDPI votera en
faveur de cette proposition de
résolution merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
madame Angèle Préville pour le groupe
socialiste pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la présidente de la
délégation en droit des femmes mesdames
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
perversion partout respect nulle part
l'industrie pornographique organise un
monde parallèle où le spectacle de
violence de sévices et de viol el
anormes la pornographie c'est infiltrée
partout dans notre société et installe
dans les esprits une vision sordide de
la sexualité c'est une activité
économique extrêmement lucrative
autrement dit une machine à cash
générant dans le monde des milliards
d'euros chaque année ce qui est plus
qu'à l'armant ce sont les taux
d'exposition des mineurs à des images
pornographiques ces massif et proprement
hallucinants avant 13 ans bien plus que
le tiers des garçons est plus du quart
des filles avant 18 ans les chiffres
nous donnent le vertige la
quasi-totalité des garçons 95% et une
très large majorité des filles 86%
rappelons-le la loi interdit l'accès des
mineurs au contenu pornographique pour
le coup nous sommes très très loin du
compte s'agissant du respect de la loi
les effets dévastateurs sur les
comportements des enfants sont d'ores et
déjà constatés multiplication des
attouchements et harcèlement sexuels
dans les collèges et les lycées
visionnage subit parce qu'imposer de
vidéos pornographiques les filles
constituant bien sûr la majorité des
victimes et ceux-ci se passe dans
l'ignorance quasi-totale des parents si
un témoignage ou une affaire est révélé
ce n'est que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg n'oublions pas que quasiment
tous les enfants ont vu des vidéos
pornographiques avant 18 ans les effets
du porno sont absolument toxiques sur
les esprits a fortiori sur les plus
jeunes chez les adolescents la rencontre
avec la brutalité du porno précède la
construction de l'imaginaire sexuel
l'enfant peut être profondément choqué
et dans l'incapacité d'analyser ce qu'il
a vu c'est tous les possibles des
rapports amoureux qui peuvent être
balayés rencontrent attirant séduction
c'est et je le dis avec force parce que
c'est grave une violence psychique qui
constitue une blessure à vie infligée
aux enfants en ne les protant protégeant
pas dès les conséquences sont délétères
notamment de nombreux troubles et
traumatismes et surtout comme un
apprentissage au nom consentement
s'ajoute à cela que les contenus sont de
plus en plus violents il ne semble pas y
avoir de limites apologies du viol de
l'inceste et tout un panel de déviance
sexuelles un nombre non négligeable de
consommateurs vont développer une
addiction entraînant une accoutumance à
des contenus de plus en plus violents
érigeant la domination masculine en
modèle dans une escalade sans fin 90%
des scènes pornographiques sont
violentes voire ultra violente elles
peuvent être qualifiées d'acte de
torture de barbarie et de traite d'êtres
humains beaucoup de femmes recrutées
sont trompées abusées et vont être
filmés alors qu'elles sont violentées
blessées violées la réalité c'est
qu'elles ont été piégées n'ayant aucune
idée de la violence inouïe des actes
sexuels qu'elles allaient subir la
rapide évolution de l'industrie
pornographique tirée par le
développement d'Internet a créé des
opportunités pour des acteurs sans
structure bâtissant des fortunes alors
que les pouvoirs publics sont restés
aveugles et sourds des uns des empires
se sont créés insaisissables et des
d'une certaine manière par l'absence de
réglementation de cadres du surveillance
résultat une réalité parallèle ou
prospère l'esclavage sexuel dont la
valeur marchande constitue une forme de
barbarie contemporaine ce monde semble
échapper à toute poursuite à toute
sanctions quant aux femmes victimes
elles se trouvent dans la quasi
impossibilité de demander justice pour
ce qu'elles ont subi si quelques
affaires ont été révélées dévoilant
l'ampleur du phénomène nous sommes
pourtant devant le constat effrayant des
chiffres 19 millions de visiteurs par
mois en France dont 17 millions
d'adultes et 2 millions d'adolescents un
marché colossal provoquant un appel
d'air à l'arrivée de nouvelle vidéo sur
les plateformes sur les plateformes pour
répondre à la demande marcher qui de
plus connaît une dérive sans précédent
en créant une passerelle avec une forme
de proxénétisme très particulier celui
du viol sur commande d'une femme pensant
elle participer au tournage d'une vidéo
pornographique la lutte est vraiment
inégale devant l'accélération du
phénomène quelle société résultera
demain de notre inaction et du manque de
protection des enfants le constat du
rapport est sans appel il faut agir sans
tarder avec volontarisme et efficacité
notamment élargir les prérogatives de
l'arcome pour sanctionner les sites qui
ne respectent pas tout simplement la loi
soit l'interdiction d'accès aux mineurs
et d'autre part généraliser la
plateforme pharose aux violences
sexuelles pour cela il faut y mettre des
moyens humains conséquents la lutte
contre la marche une marchandisation du
corps des femmes doit être une priorité
absolue de politique publique alors que
les violences exercées par les hommes
sur les femmes ne baissent pas dans
notre pays on peut légitimement se
questionner voire même s'inquiéter du
rôle que joue la consommation massive de
pornographie merci très sincèrement à la
délégation au droit des femmes de ce
travail au combien nécessaire et
courageux sur ce que vous avez très
justement appelé l'enfer du décor le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain votera cette proposition de
résolution
merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Marie-Claude varailla
pour le groupe CRCE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues aujourd'hui nous
examinons une résolution importante qui
appelle à faire de la lutte contre les
violences pornographiques une priorité
de politique publique un principe de
réalité s'impose à nous mes chers
collègues nous vivons dans une société
où la pornographie est omniprésente et
où les violences sexuelles y sont
malheureusement aussi très présentes car
oui la pornographie contribue à la
culture du viol et à la normalisation de
la violence sexuelle les images
violentes et dégradantes qui sont
représentées ont un impact réel sur la
façon dont les hommes et les femmes se
perçoivent eux-mêmes c'est pourquoi nous
devons nous opposer fermement à une
industrie opaque et mondialisée qui
exploite et objective le corps des
femmes et des minorités de genre nous
devons comprendre que le porno est un
produit culturel qui se nourrit des
discriminations de genre dans notre
société pour générer des de profit en
effet l'excellent rapport de nos
collègues mettant relief dans que dans
la pornographie les femmes et les
minorités de genre ils sont souvent
relégués à des rôles stéréotypés et
dégradants tandis que le mythe de la
performance masculine y est sur
représentée il est grand temps de
dénoncer cette représentation des sexes
biaisés qui renforcent les inégalités
existantes et nourrit la culture de la
violence sexuelle en outre nous ne
manquerons pas de pointer du doigt une
industrie sans aucun scrupule dans
laquelle les actrices pornographiques
sont victimes d'exploitation de
harcèlement et de violence sexuelles de
plus par cette résolution nous
souhaitons dénoncer une industrie du
porno qui a des répercussions néfastes
sur la santé physique et mentale des
acteurs et des spectateurs d'une part
les actrices pornographiques sont
exposées à des infections sexuellement
transmissibles à des de stress post
traumatique à des troubles de
l'alimentation et à d'autres problèmes
de santé mentale d'autre part les
spectateurs de porno peuvent développer
des addictions des troubles de la
sexualité et des problèmes de santé
mentale mes chers collègues il est
impératif que nous prenions des mesures
pour contrer les effets nocifs de la
pornographie actuelle sur notre société
en particulier comme l'a évoqué ma
collègue Laurence Cohen nous devons
fournir des ressources pour éduquer le
public sur les dangers de la
pornographie et sur les moyens de
résister à ces effets néfastes cela peut
inclure des campagnes de sensibilisation
ou encore des programmes éducatifs pour
promouvoir une éducation sexuelle qui
met en avant la diversité des identités
de genre et des orientations sexuelles
qui respectent la dignité et l'autonomie
de chacune et qui lutte contre les
stéréotypes sexistes et homophobes ces
mesures sont plus que nécessaires que
l'on sait qu'en France deux tiers et ça
a été dit par mes précédents collègues
deux tiers des moines de 15 ans déjà
visionné des images pornographiques et
2,3 millions de jeunes de moins de 18
ans en visionnerait tous les mois de
plus nous plaidons en faveur de mesure
pour lutter contre l'exploitation des
actrices dans l'industrie pornographique
il est grand temps de travailler à créer
des espaces sur et égalitaires afin de
protéger leur dignité et leur intégrité
physique et mentale les violences
systémiques qu'elles subissent doivent
cesser enfin nous devons renforcer les
lois et les politiques qui protègent les
victimes de la violence sexuelle et de
l'exploitation dans l'industrie
pornographique en France la justice
commence à ouvrir les yeux avec la ferme
French bunk cake c'était la première
fois en France que des acteurs sont
poursuivis pour viol dans des
investigations visant l'industrie
pornographique et nous n'y voyons nous y
voyons un premier pas vers la
reconnaissance du fait que les actrices
pornographiques ne sont pas des
citoyennes de seconde zone leur plainte
à la police doivent être prises au
sérieux une meilleure formation des
policiers et nécessaires au recueil de
telles dénonciation en outre le droit à
l'oubli ne doit pas être à deux vitesses
pour les actrices du porno faut-il donc
rappeler que certaines ont dû débourser
entre 3 et 5000 euros pour faire retirer
des vidéos des vidéos en ligne dans
lesquels elles apparaissaient en faisant
valoir leurs droits à l'oubli cela n'est
pas acceptable nous ne pouvons demeurer
les bras croisés et à ce propos madame
la ministre j'ai envie de vous demander
que comptez-vous faire des
recommandations de ce rapport qui
méritent à l'évidence que nous agissions
mes chers collègues la violence sexuelle
dans la pornographie est un problème de
société qui nécessite des réponses
collectives en adoptant cette résolution
nous nous engageons en faveur de la
lutte contre les violences
pornographiques nous attendons qu'elle
soit érigée en priorité de politique
publique afin de mieux éduquer face à
ces dangers et protéger les actrices
pornographiques très souvent victimes de
violences sexuelles c'est une
responsabilité que nous devons tous
partager et un engagement que nous
devons prendre c'est pourquoi le groupe
CRCE dont l'ensemble des membres est
signataires votera bien évidemment cette
proposition de résolution
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Loïc Hervé pour le
groupe Union centriste pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avant toute chose et
comme tous les collègues qui se
succèdent à cette tribune cet après-midi
je tiens à saluer le travail
exceptionnel qui a été effectué par
notre délégation droit des femmes en
particulier par nos collègues la
présidente Annick Billon et nos
collègues Alexandra borquio fontin
Laurence Cohen et Laurence Rossignol
auteur du rapport d'information porno
l'enfer du décor not émane la présente
proposition de résolution il s'agit d'un
travail véritablement pionnier aussi
incroyable que cela soit alors que la
pornographie est à l'évidence devenue un
problème social majeur le Parlement ne
l'avait jamais véritablement investi
avec ce rapport de formation et cette
proposition de résolution la
représentation nationale ouvre enfin les
yeux il était temps contre les préjugés
les plus communément répandus c'est
évidemment tout un honneur de notre
haute assemblée d'avoir porté cette
prise de conscience je tiens donc à
affirmer sans ambiguïté que je soutiens
sans réserve chacun des considérants de
cette proposition de résolution dont je
suis moi-même consignateur
la question qui est devant nous est
importante madame la ministre après la
publication du rapport l'adoption je
l'imagine tout à l'heure de cette
résolution
tout cela nous entraînera madame la
ministre sans doute vers un texte de loi
et posera nécessairement la question
d'adoption de mesure pragmatiques pour
être efficace
l'interdiction pure et simple de la
pornographie est un chemin que certains
de nos collègues nous proposeront
peut-être d'emprunter sans préempter sur
ce débat je crois pouvoir affirmer que
la prohibition pourrait générer
immédiatement la bascule de la
pornographie dans la contrebande et la
mafia qu'ils ont des mots encore pire
que ceux que nous connaissons déjà
aujourd'hui et qui ont été longuement
évoqués existe-t-il une pornographie
éthique existe-t-il une pornographie
morale est-ce notre rôle d'y répondre
dans les débats à venir je serai de ceux
qui défendront un encadrement strict
c'est un chemin de crête qui demande de
la conviction mais qui a mes yeux et le
seul qui soit en mesure de produire de
réels effets sur la réalité vécue dans
notre pays alors pour encadrer la
pornographie nous avons tout à fait et
c'est bien ce travail que nous invite à
mes yeux encore une fois
cette présente résolution
la seule pornographie qui puisse exister
se doit de respecter la loi mais avant
tout la personne humaine et bien
évidemment les femmes
c'est une pornographie d'alcool de
d'adulte consentant et qui ne s'adresse
qu'à eux aucune tolérance pour les viols
ce sont des crimes aucune tolérance pour
les abus de faiblesse ni la prostitution
et encore moins le proxénétisme c'est
d'ailleurs ce que considère la Cour de
cassation qui dans sa décision du 18 mai
à
refuser d'étendre la définition
jurisprudentielle de la notion de
prostitution à l'activité dite de
Camille constituant à proposer moyennant
rémunération une diffusion d'image ou de
vidéos à contenu sexuel pour séparer le
bon grain de livret un cadre transversal
doit être créé de toute pièce car
schématiquement on peut classer les
problèmes causés par la pornographie en
deux grandes familles
ce lié aux personnes qui la font et se
lier au personnes qui ont accès la
protection des premières c'est à dire
principalement des actrices
posent la question des conditions de
travail ça a été évoqué par plusieurs
collègues et des conditions de tournage
dans la production de tout ces contenus
pornographiques c'est la seule solution
pour prévenir les crimes telles que ceux
qui ont récemment défrayé la chronique
et qui sont d'ailleurs devant des
juridictions de notre pays c'est son
même ses crimes qui sont à l'origine de
notre prise de conscience collective
quant à l'énorme problème de l'accès de
nos enfants et de nos adolescents il
soulève l'impérieuse nécessité des
plaques que les plateformes soient
contraintes à vérifier l'âge la CNIL a
fait des propositions et il y a monsieur
le Président je suis un peu long mais il
y a eu un élément qui est très important
et j'en terminerai par là et qui a un
autre dieu doit être un élément de
réflexion c'est la régulation également
des messageries instantanées qui sont un
champ extrêmement important vous l'aurez
compris dans mes propos le groupe de
l'Union centriste votera cette
proposition de résolution sans aucune
réserve
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Esther Benbassa pour
les non inscrits pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
rapporteurs madame la ministre mes chers
collègues le ministre en charge du
numérique Jean-Noël Barrault déclaré
récemment je le cite en 2023 c'est la
fin de l'accès au site pornographique
pour nos enfants à seulement 12 ans près
d'un enfant sur trois a été exposé à du
contenu pornographique en ligne
l'interdiction d'accès au site porno
mineur manque sa cible quand il est
juste demandé à l'internaute de répondre
en cliquant oui à la question de
confiance sur sa majorité
conscient de cette faille le
gouvernement prévoit une face test à
compter à partir de ce mois pour bloquer
toute consultation de site porno au
mineur de fait la jeunesse est trop
souvent confrontée ici à une
représentation déformée et inégalitaire
des rapports hommes femmes
ces contenus accessibles facilement
toujours plus violents font la promotion
de l'acte sexuel forcé or selon une
étude de la BBC plus d'un tiers des
femmes subissent des violences lors de
l'acte sexuel c'est pratique ne
sont-elles pas encouragées par la
consommation d'un certain type de
pornographie il est urgent d'agir mais
comment
la corrélation de violence sexuelle et
pornographie s'observe déjà au niveau
des conditions de travail imposées aux
actrices lesquelles relèvent pourtant du
Code du travail censé les protéger notre
législation a clairement échoué
jusqu'ici à dissiper les flux juridiques
entourant les métiers de la pornographie
comment protéger les actrices sans les
empêcher d'exercer leur métier il ne
s'agit pas d'aggraver leur précarité en
espérant abolir le porno mais de doté de
l'Arsenal législative capable à la fois
de garantir efficacement le consentement
et la dignité des actrices et de
sanctionner efficacement les producteurs
encourageant les actes de violence lors
des tournages la pornographie relève du
débat public cette résolution pourrait
servir de points de départ à l'écriture
d'un projet de loi sans oublier que le
problème posé n'est pas un problème
français mais international et que
l'Europe devrait collectivement sans
saisir et sans oublier non plus
qu'encadrer et punir ne suffit pas et
que la clé est aussi comme le suggène
amias fini vas-y professeur à Oxford une
éducation rappelant à nos jeunes que le
sexe peut rester ce que les Anciens
générations en ont fait mais qu'il peut
aussi si eux-mêmes le choisissent je
suis devenu quelque chose de plus joyeux
de plus égalitaire de plus libre merci
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
Madame Valérie Boyer pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues pendant plus de six
mois la délégation du droit des femmes a
mener des travaux sur l'industrie de la
pornographie et ces travaux ont abouti
un rapport porno l'enfer du décor je
veux remercier la présidente de la
délégation du droit des femmes Annick
billon d'avoir permis ce travail de fond
au côté de nos rapporteurs Alexandra
porchio Fontain Laurence Cohen Laurence
Rossignol pour le formidable travail qui
a été fait je voudrais vous féliciter
parce que votre travail fait avancer à
la fois les mentalités mais je l'espère
aussi notre droit plus de 250 sénateurs
dont cette présidente groupe ont
souhaité être associé à cette résolution
le Sénat a pleinement conscience
d'urgence et de l'importance de ce sujet
et même si des mesures iront dans le
sens de la protection des mineurs face à
l'exposition de la pornographie ne
passons pas à côté d'un autre enjeu dont
je voudrais vous parler tout en
soulignant quand même que cette
industrie pornographique réalise un
hold-up sur l'intimité et le
développement de nos plus jeunes en 2018
j'avais auditionné à l'Assemblée
nationale le journaliste Robin d'Angelo
qui venait de publier le livre du jeudi
Lola Sofia et moi pendant un an il
s'était infiltré dans le milieu du porno
soi-disant amateur un carnet en France
par la puissante entreprise Jacquie et
Michel aussi alors que nous sommes
interrogés à juste titre pendant des
années sur l'exposition et l'accès des
jeunes la pornographie nous avions
occulté tout un pan de ce sujet si grave
il avait expliqué ce que personne
n'osait dire à l'époque l'absence
récurrente de consentement le non
respect du droit du travail et des
pratiques contraires à la dignité
humaine dignité humaine n'ayant pas peur
des mots il parle d'une forme de
normalisation de la violence assez
marquante et assez forte je le cite qui
conduit forcément à des abus ce sont des
abus ce ne sont pas des films ce sont
des scènes de violence et dès 2020 ces
actes éclatèrent au grand jour avec
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
pour traite d'être humain
viol aggravé en réunion ou proxénétique
m'aggravée contre la plateforme de vidéo
pornographiques French Buck cake de
graves atteintes au consentement pour
des scènes dégradantes et très violentes
sont mentionnées par les plaignantes et
leur équisitoire du parquet feraient
état de viols répétés de mensonges
d'intimidation et de l'utilisation de
drogue quelquefois leur insu de tests
VIH falsifié et de raquettes pour
retirer les vidéos portes
pédopornographique pardon qui empoisonne
leur vie de même l'ouverture d'une
deuxième information judiciaire dans le
cadre d'une procédure distincte à
l'encontre notamment des sociétés
Jacquie et Michel un décident
pornographiques français les plus
consultés pour complicité de viol et
traite d'êtres humains en bon organisé a
été réalisé ces procédures témoignent de
la volonté des enquêteurs et de la
justice de porter une plus grande
attention aux violences sexistes et
sexuelles commises dans le milieu dit du
porno français sans compter toutes les
victimes qui n'ont jamais
osé parler c'est près de 220 000 vidéos
vu chaque minute sur la principale
plateforme où se cache parfois des
réseaux criminels lunettes et de trade
d'êtres humains à grande échelle c'est
une industrie prospère une recherche sur
8 sur un ordi concerne une vidéo porno
ayant le courage de dire que les
méthodes de l'industrie pornographique
sont trop souvent identiques à celles
des réseaux de traite d'être humain
c'est de la traite d'être humain
d'ailleurs rabattage mise en confiance
soumission par le viol exploitation
mi-souterreur inversion de la
culpabilité et chantage les tournages
des actes sexuels sous contrainte
économiques et morales des agressions
sexuelles et des viols voire des actes
de torture et de barbarie doivent être
lourdement condamnés c'est pourquoi mes
chers collègues nous ne pouvons pas
voter dans cette émission des lois pour
protéger les victimes de violence
sexuelle et fermez les yeux ou même
tolérer ce qui se passe bien trop
souvent dans ces entreprises du porno et
c'est pourquoi je crois que le Sénat
peut être fier de proposer notamment de
faire des violences sexuelles commises
en de contexte de pornographie un délit
d'incitation à une infraction pénale de
favoriser l'émergence de plein de
victimes de silence commise dans un
contexte de pornographie en améliorant
leurs conditions d'accueil en formant
des forces de l'ordre au recueil des
plaines de ces victimes spécifiques en
instaurant le suivi de leur dossier par
un contact unique de traduire dans les
effectifs et les moyens matériels des
services d'enquête et des magistrats la
priorité donnée à la lutte contre les
violences collectes dans un contexte
pornographique ou en s'attaquant
directement au plateforme de diffusion
car ces femmes et parfois ces hommes
nous ne vont pas les oublier doivent à
la fois se reconstruire mais supporter
la diffusion non contrelée de leurs
vidéos dont elles sont victimes alors
mes chers collègues je sais
qu'aujourd'hui il est de notre
responsabilité de porter le message de
ses victimes et de ses victimes qui sont
aussi bien les personnes qui les
regardent que celles qui sont exposées
dans ces films c'est soi-disant acteurs
qui subissent ces violences votez cette
résolution s'il te dit dire à toutes ces
victimes nous sommes avec vous soyons
fiers en votant ces propositions pour
protéger ces hommes et ces femmes
exploitées nous les défendons la liberté
mais surtout la fraternité parce que la
solidarité que nous leur devons est très
importante et je crois que aujourd'hui
que les votants ce texte et cette raison
et bien nous protégeons la dignité
humaine je vous remercie merci pour
votre travail
la parole est à Monsieur Serge mériou
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames Mesdames et Messieurs chers
collègues dans l'enfer des films porno
le nom n'existe pas le oui et la norme
malheureusement la réalité des passes
parfois la fiction quand ce rapport au
consentement ou plutôt ou non
consentement s'invite sur les tournages
et s'immises dans le cerveau des
consommateurs le porno c'est avant tout
la mise en avant d'une vision très
singulière misogyne de la sexualité une
sexualité majoritaire
le porno c'est une vision violente
brutale dans laquelle les femmes sont
souvent réduites à l'état d'objet dont
on peut disposer sans limite
les insultes les propos dégradants se
substituent au sentiment les coups
caresses les cris à la passion les gros
pas les gros plats à la tendresse la
réalité est bien différente pourtant
c'est à cette conception toute
particulière de la sexualité à laquelle
nos enfants sont exposés
on a déjà dit mais en effet deux tiers
des enfants de moins de 15 ans et un
tiers des enfants de moins de 12 ans ont
déjà eu accès à des contenus
pornographiques c'est le triste constat
que tirent les autrices de cette PPR
smartphone tablette ordinateur avec le
numérique chaque enfant chaque
adolescent des tenteurs d'un de ses
appareils peut se rendre sur des sites
pornos et être exposés à de la
pornographie la plupart du temps l'accès
n'est conditionné qu'à un clic sur un
bouton j'ai plus de 18 ans un rap un
rempart en carton facilement
franchissable par quiconque sa chance
servir d'une souris ce clic des pourtant
pas sans conséquence pour un cerveau en
plein développement pour un jeune en
pleine construction
l'exposition à la pornographie et pour
certains une première approche de la
sexualité une découverte qui parfois
débute par le visionnage d'un vol à
réunion d'un viol à réunion d'une vidéo
hardcore en effet des contenus violents
dégradants sont souvent mis en avant sur
les sites
l'impact sur les enfants dans la
représentation qu'ils se font des femmes
et des hommes de la sexualité des
différentes orientations sexuelles est
indéniable et destructeur
traumatisme trouble du sommeil de
l'alimentation vision déformée violente
de la sexualité des effets sont graves
cette vision rétrograde violente et
basée sur les rapports de domination
entre les individus cette vision
instaurée par le porno véhicule
également des clichés des préjugés
racistes laissent vos formes homophobe
et transphobe qui revient de combattre
lutter contre cette exposition à des
mineurs des mineurs à la pornographie
n'est pas chose simple beaucoup des
parents pensent contrôler les pratiques
web de leur enfant malheureusement la
pornographie est partout twitter
facebook snapchat telegram redite qui
s'agisse de continuer directement sur
ces plateformes ou de liens envoyés par
message privé nos jeunes sont exposés de
toutes parts mes chers collègues il nous
faut protéger nos enfants et en ce sens
je remercie les autrices de ce PPR qui
font des propositions pertinentes mieux
contrôler l'accès aux plateformes est
impératif elles doivent respecter la loi
l'exposition d'un mineur à des contenus
pornographiques est un délit durcissant
les conditions de vérification de l'âge
enfin il est essentiel d'accélérer des
initiatives de prévention et de
sensibilisation à destination des
parents et des enfants ces derniers
doivent avoir davantage d'informations
relatives à la sexualité à leur
disposition pour que leur seul modèle ne
soit pas la pornographie en ce sens
l'école et l'État doivent jouer un rôle
mes chers collègues cette position
transposition par de bon sens et bien
sûr le groupe socialiste écologique et
républicains de la votera merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Catherine Morin
Dessailly pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues avec cette
proposition de résolution contre les
violences pornographiques que nous
examinons aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement une priorité publique avec
le développement de l'Internet les
conduits pornographiques sont devenus
quasiment libres d'accès via un
ordinateur ou un téléphone or comme le
démontre le remarquable travail de nos
collègues de la délégation droit des
femmes ces contenus diffusent des images
souvent dégradantes reposant sur des
maltraitances des viols ou du
proxinitisme y compris de mineurs et on
assiste une banalisation la diffusion de
ce type de contenu pour le plus grand
bénéfice d'une industrie qui elle
prospère c'est pourquoi comme l'a dit
notre collègue Loïc Hervé le groupe de
l'Union centriste votera cette
proposition de résolution visant à
susciter une prise de conscience dans
notre pays pour améliorer le soutien aux
victimes renforcer la réponse pénale
contre ces violences empêcher la
diffusion de ses contenus illicites et
protéger notre jeunesse côté réponse
pénale nous disposons déjà d'un outil
exemplaire réuni en Europe la plateforme
Pharos regroupant policiers gendar cette
plateforme effectue une veille
d'Internet et dispose des moyens
juridiques et techniques pour retirer
les contenus illicites ou en bloquer
l'accès sur la base de signalement tout
ceci sous le contrôle d'une personnalité
qualifiée Laurence peccot Rivollier
membre de l'arcom j'ai pu échanger avec
eux leur témoignage sont atterrants à la
limite du supportable lorsqu'il s'agit
d'enfants ou même de nourrissons leur
travail est exemplaire la création d'une
catégorie violence sexuelle serait
effectivement bienvenue mais les moyens
de farose doivent être alignés sur cette
ambition en particulier la personnalité
qualifiée dont le travail est très
éprouvant et qui mériterait d'être
remplacé par une structure collégiale
maintenant la régulation sur Internet
dépend aussi et principalement d'un
législation européenne le digital
services Isaac récemment voté prévoit
que les autorités des États membres
peuvent demander aux fournisseur d'agir
contre les contenus illicites je
regrette toutefois et je l'ai maintes
fois dit que la responsabilité des
fournisseurs de services d'hébergement
dont on connaît le modèle économique
particulièrement toxiques demeure
limitée dans la diffusion de ce type de
contenu n'oublions pas qu'ici même
Francisco gun la lanceur d'alerte nous
avertissez que facebook privilégiera
toujours le profit à la sécurité des
enfants ainsi dans la proposition de
résolution européenne sur la lutte
contre les abus sexuels sur les enfants
en ligne qui a été adoptés par notre
commission des affaires européennes le
15 février dernier avec mes collègues
Ludovic et André Ray Charles nous avons
redis cela et nous avons proposé aussi
que la Commission européenne puisse
indiquer au public quel fournisseur ne
respectent pas leurs obligations tout
cela dans une logique de nemen shame
afin que le risque réputationnel les
incite à respecter scrupuleusement la
réglementation ensuite merci aux auteurs
de la proposition pour leur mesure
visant à mieux protéger notre jeunesse
notamment la mise en place de
dispositifs de contrôle parental à
activer par défaut sur les appareils ou
l'écran noir qui seraient imposés au
site je vérifie pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs ces recommandations
confortent celles que nous avons faites
avec mes cours à porteurs pour mieux
lutter contre la pédopornographie cette
Luna nécessite des efforts plus que
redoublés au niveau national comme au
niveau européen car elle constitue une
délinquance de masse multiforme qui
prolifèrent ainsi en 2021 l'agence
policière européenne Europole que j'ai
pu visiter il y a une quinzaine de jours
démantelez le réseau boystown qui
comptait 400 000 utilisateurs sur les
Dark web on peut aussi rappeler
l'enquête ouverte contre Tik Tok l'an
dernier pour son non signalement de
contenu pédopornographique l'Union
européenne détient hélas un triste
record mes chers collègues celui du
premier hébergeur de contenu à caractère
pédopornographique dans le monde et en
France selon Madame pecorivolier sur
150000 contenus litigieux examinés par
elle en 2021 environ 70% étaient des
contenus à caractère pédo pornographique
en majorité publiée et détenue par des
hommes tout âge toutes catégories
socio-professionnelle confondues voilà
pourquoi il y a urgence pourquoi la
France doit être faire de lance au
niveau européen pour instituer des
obligations
pour son excellent
mais Morin de saillie franchement c'est
pas bien parce qu'il y en a un autre
texte derrière c'est un peu de respect
pour les autres
mais Marie merci c'est à vous pour 4
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la délégation
droit des femmes
mes chers collègues co-rapporteur que je
félicite pour leur excellent travail mes
chers collègues en quelques clics sur
leur téléphone les petites Marceaux
loups Noé peuvent aujourd'hui très
facilement visionner des contenus
pornographiques disponibles gratuitement
en ligne même lorsqu'ils mettent en
scène des pratiques violentes
douloureuses humiliantes voire des viols
est-ce acceptable les conséquences sur
nos enfants sur leur développement
affectif psychologique et sexuel sont
alarmantes nous l'avons vu donc nos
mineurs peuvent accéder à des contenus
gratuits mais pas à des sites
pornographiques payants n'est-ce pas
curieux en 2020 le Sénat était saisi
d'une PPL visant à protéger les victimes
de violences conjugales présentées par
des députés de la majorité rapporteur de
ce texte qui inclut l'accès des mineurs
aussi pornographiques j'ai donc procédé
à des auditions complémentaires afin de
pouvoir proposer au Sénat un dispositif
à la des enjeux n'inspirant d'une mesure
en vigueur depuis 10 ans pour les gens
en ligne j'ai proposé un amendement
visant à instituer une nouvelle
prostituée à obliger les éditeurs des
sites pornographiques à mettre en place
un contrôle de l'âge de leurs clients
mes chers collègues vous avez voté mon
amendement à l'unanimité le 10 juin 2020
je vous en remercie il donne des
prérogatives à la comme que je ne vais
pas détailler quel bilan depuis le vote
de cette loi visant à protéger les
victimes de violences conjugales du 31
juillet 2020 pourquoi faut-il déployer
tant d'énergie pour être entendu alors
qu'il s'agit bien là d'une priorité
publique d'une loi votée de la
protection de l'enfance rappelle des
faits le décret d'application de mon
amendement n'a été pris en compte que le
7 octobre 2021 soit 14 mois plus tard
pourquoi 5 sites pornographiques parmi
les plus regardés sont alors sommets de
ce pli à cette loi ni mise en demeure
sont restés sans effet malgré les
constats d'huissiers plus de
le président du tribunal judiciaire de
Paris est saisi en septembre 2022 la
justice française examine la demande de
blocage de ces sites et en juin
finalement l'arcane de rencontrer un
médiateur vous avez bien entendu un
médiateur c'est du jamais vu de leur
côté les sites déposent une QPC la Cour
de cassation refuse heureusement leur
argument le 5 janvier 2023 c'est une
petite victoire pour nos enfants l'arcom
confronté à des sites pornographiques
usant de manœuvres dilatoire pour éviter
un blocage par la justice a récemment
mis fin à ce processus de médiation
inutile incompréhensible et choquant le
ministre barreau a annoncé tester fin
mars un système de vérification d'âge en
double anonymat qui ne laisse perplexe
testez mais jusqu'à quand cette solution
devrait avoir fait ses preuves avant de
pouvoir être étendue quand sera-t-elle
mise en place définitivement en
attendant que va faire la justice
reporter ses décisions et pendant
combien de temps et pendant ce temps-là
nos petits Jules Gabin peuvent continuer
de voir de la pornographie gratuite
enfin et pour moi c'est le plus
important ce système des responsabilise
les sites pornographiques gratuits mon
amendement leur impose pourtant de
vérifier l'âge de leur visiteurs comme
d'autres sites savent le faire les
outils législatifs sont en place il faut
seulement se préoccuper de faire
appliquer la loi avec une vraie volonté
politique et des moyens après une
intervention mes chers collègues les
pompiers emploient une très jolie
formule ils évaluent le sauver
depuis l'adoption de cette loi
peut-on évaluer le nombre d'enfants
protégés de ces contenus qui ne sont pas
faits pour eux quel est le sauver c'est
facile à évaluer je vais vous le dire la
loi n'est pas appliquée madame la
ministre le sauver c'est zéro je vous
laisse juge
merci beaucoup
alors je la parole est à madame Isabelle
Rome ministre délégué chargé d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances
madame la présidente madame de la
présidente de la délégation au droit des
femmes cher Annick mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs en
préambule je tiens à souligner mesdames
les sénatrices beyon bourquieux fontin
Cohen et Rossignol la qualité du rapport
que vous avez produit en octobre dernier
vos travaux jettent la lumière sur des
faits de société trop souvent passé sous
silence mais qui porte en eux une
violence inouïe à l'égard des femmes vos
travaux contribuent à faire évoluer les
mentalités et permettent au Parlement
pour la première fois de mettre ce sujet
à l'ordre du jour
je sais aussi que vous avez fait preuve
d'une grande force en recevant les
victimes et en écoutant les croyable
récits des sévices qu'elles ont subi
aujourd'hui parmi les termes les plus
recherchés sur les plateformes
pornographiques on trouve sexe brutal
ado amateurs
ou encore ado vierge ces termes ne sont
pas des fantasmes ils sont des appels à
la violence au crime il peut s'agir aux
nommer les choses de viol avec torture
et acte de barbarie punissable de la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité je
tiens donc à remercier les sénatrices
qui ont conduit ce travail d'avoir fait
la lumière sur ce tabou
chaque seconde que sont tues les
violences pornographiques est une
seconde souffrance pour des milliers de
victimes des milliers de femmes abusées
à force de pression financière et
psychologiques ces femmes se sont par
exemple toutes celles qui sont
condamnées à vivre avec un cauchemar qui
se répète chaque fois qu'un utilisateur
appuie sur play et qui attendent le
jugement de leur agresseur c'est aussi
pour elle que nous devons agir c'est en
pensant à chacune d'elles que je parle
devant vous aujourd'hui elles sont les
victimes de la violence de l'industrie
pornographique j'utilise le thème
industrie à dessin car c'est violence
répondent à la demande des consommateurs
pour y mettre fin sur le long terme la
réponse pénale ne suffit pas
nous devons protéger et sensibiliser les
plus jeunes aux dérives de la
pornographie vous l'avez rappelé sur les
19 millions de personnes qui en France
visitent chaque jour un site
pornographique il y a un million
d'adolescents qui ont entre 15 et 18 ans
et
1,2 millions d'enfants âgés de moins de
15 ans la violence des sites
pornographiques et souvent pour eux le
premier aperçu de ce qu'est la sexualité
et cela se traduit chez nombre de jeunes
par une vision déformée et violente des
rapports sexuels qui peut aussi
entraîner des difficultés à construire
et entretenir des relations affectives
en tant que magistrates je peux
l'affirmer il y a là un terreau très
favorable à des comportements violents
envers les femmes
une des clés réside dans l'éducation
l'école de la République doit être un
lieu de savoir d'émancipation et
d'éducation la citoyenneté depuis 2001
la loi prévoit que l'éducation à la
sexualité doit être dispensée dans les
écoles les collèges et les lycées à
raison de trois séances annuelles des
séances d'éducation à la sexualité
fondée sur un apprentissage du respect
de l'autre sur nos valeurs cardinales du
respect de soi et de l'autre d'égalité
et sur l'apprentissage du consentement
dès notre arrivée au gouvernement avec
mon collègue Papé N'Diaye nous avons
fait de l'application de cette loi l'une
de nos priorités nous devons porter un
message pédagogique fort à destination
de notre jeunesse nous avons pris le
problème à bras le corps le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a publié le
rapport produit en juillet 2021 par
l'inspection générale de l'éducation du
sport et de la recherche
il a publié également sur son site
invadimicon de l'éducation à la
sexualité afin d'en exposer le contenu
et les enjeux et depuis février donc
depuis quelques semaines un groupe de
travail interministériel a été mise en
place pour élaborer ou renouveler
actualiser les contenus et les
ressources pédagogiques et renforcées
les formations des personnels
pédagogiques notre message éducatif doit
être assez puissant pour mettre un mal
l'idéologie patriarcale et méprisante
pour les femmes que diffuse trop souvent
les plateformes quelle qu'elle soit car
il serait erroné de penser que l'on ne
peut trouver la violence pornographie
que sur les sites dédiés le rapport
l'illus parfaitement les plateformes
telles que Twitter meta Tik Tok ou
snapchat héberge aussi ses contenus
d'une grande violence
par cette proposition de résolution nous
devons exprimer une position claire sur
un sujet que la société doit enfin
regarder en face à mon initiative des
discussions interministérielles sont
actuellement en cours pour prendre des
mesures fortes à l'encontre des
diffuseurs qui ne pourront plus se
cacher derrière un prétendu pseudo vide
juridique votre travail mesdames
messenatrices apporter ses fruits
d'abord avec cette proposition de
résolution que vous examinez aujourd'hui
et puis ensuite par le travail qui est
en cours pour imposer aux plateformes
qu'un travail car pardon qu'un contrôle
efficace de l'âge de l'internaute soit
enfin mise en place et ce grâce à
l'engagement de mes collègues
Eric Dupont-Moretti Jean-Noël Barrault
et Charlotte cobel
le décret prévoyant le contrôle parental
sur tous les terminaux sera promulgués
prochainement je tiens par ailleurs à
rappeler la campagne gouvernementale
ambitieuse lancée à l'occasion du
Internet seferday grâce au site je
protège mon enfant.gouv.fr nous offrons
enfin aux parents les outils dont ils
ont besoin pour préserver leurs enfants
des contenus violents ce qu'est la
pornographie nous voulons aller plus
loin un travail est en cours également
sur les prérogatives de l'arcome et je
suis aussi particulièrement attachée à
améliorer les possibilités de retrait
des images intimes divulguées à la suite
des personnes
et parce que ces problématiques
dépassent nos frontières la
collaboration internationale est
essentielle pour réellement porter un
coup d'arrêt à cette violence j'étais en
Suède hier pour échanger avec mon
homologue sur les bonnes pratiques mises
en place dans nos pays respectifs nous
allons approfondir notre coopération sur
le sujet
mesdames messenatrices en votant cette
proposition de résolution vous
soutiendrez la politique ambitieuse
que mène votre gouvernement face à ce
fléau et messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai dit madame monsieur n'est triste
que c'était les c'était les rédactrices
de ce rapport voilà en votant cette
proposition de résolution vous aiderez
les victimes à ne plus se sentir seul
face à cette industrie violente
j'espère
que ces femmes nous entendent cet
après-midi
ensemble nous devons faire face à cette
responsabilité qui est la nôtre je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre
alors nous allons procéder au vote sur
la proposition de résolution la
Conférence des Présidents a décidé que
les interventions des orateurs valaient
explications de vote alors je mets aux
voix la proposition de résolution qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
adopter
à l'unanimité
alors je vais demander à chacun de
rejoindre sa place je vais pas suspendre
la séance on va démarrer de suite